three major US cities are suing the
Pentagon for an alleged failure to tell
them when service members are
disqualified from owning a gun New York
City Philadelphia and San Francisco
filed that lawsuit yesterday they want
defense officials to openly report all
military criminal convictions David
Martin is at the Pentagon with the legal
action and the government responds David
good morning good morning the Defense
Department's mission is to protect the
United States but a lawsuit filed by
three big city mayors claims the
Pentagon's repeated failures to report
violent criminals to the FBI have
actually put the public in danger
the lawsuit stems from last month's
Texas church massacre by a former member
of the Air Force
Devon Kelly was able to buy the gun he
used to kill 26 worshippers and
Sutherland Springs just outside San
Antonio because the Air Force failed to
report his conviction for a domestic
assault to the FBI if the conviction had
been reported Kelly's name would have
been entered into the database of people
barred from purchasing firearms the Air
Force admitted it failed to report
several dozen other violent offenders as
well San Francisco city attorney Dennis
Herrera Belize Court intervention is
needed to make sure the Defense
Department does its job in the future
it's unfortunate that it took that
tragedy to highlight and bring out into
the mainstream what has been going on
for all too long and that is a
department offense his failure to live
up to its responsibilities according to
the lawsuit filed by the Democratic
mayors of New York Philadelphia and San
Francisco a 2017 Defense Department
study revealed the Air Force failed to
submit final reports in about 14% of
cases the Navy and Marines in about 36%
of cases and the Army in about 41%
Pentagon's Inspector General told
Congress earlier this month such
failures were long-running and
widespread among all the armed services
inadequate training inadequate
verification they didn't take these
recommendations as seriously as they
should have
the Pentagon has promised to fix the
problem but the lawsuit asks the judge
to compel the military to go back over
all cases and report all the violent
offenders it failed to report to the FBI
the first time the Justice Department is
reviewing the lawsuit to determine its
next step Dana
David Martin at the Pentagon David thank
you